[Musique]
oui
une distribution de nourriture organisée
par l'onu a lieu ce matin là dans ce
village reculé à l'entrée des femmes qui
ne sont pas sur la liste des
bénéficiaires
mon mari a contracté une dette il est
parti où est il allé je ne sais pas
avez vous un tuteur masculin
je n'en ai pas on peut pas vous accorder
des aides pour le moment seuls ceux qui
ont été recensés par les autorités
locales peuvent entrer dans l'enclos
je ne possède rien si je ne recevais pas
cette aide je n'aurais pas d'autre choix
que de mendier
la population dans ce district ovide
essentiellement de l'agriculture
or les terres ici sont frappés par des
épisodes à répétition de sécheresse
sévère
ça c'est une super c vlc pour les femmes
enceintes ou celles qui viennent
d'accoucher qui allaitent
il ya eu la guerre puis le changement de
régime politique
puis la sécheresse tous ces problèmes se
sont conjugués c'est pourquoi c'était
donner une seconde chance aux gens mais
nous avons dû réduire le nombre de
bénéficiaires à 4250 et une personne ça
représente une baisse de 40%
l'onu est contrainte de réduire d'ici la
fin du mois de juin le nombre de
bénéficiaires de ces distributions par
manque de financement et ont raison des
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
nous récupérons des cartes celui dont la
carte n'est pas rendue aujourd'hui ne
recevra pas des de la prochaine fois
j'ai perdu ma jambe dans l'explosion
d'une mine et maintenant j'ai cette
prothèse je suis handicapé que dois-je
faire
à quelques kilomètres de là dans ce camp
de déplacés internes les aides
internationales ont cessé avec la prise
du pouvoir par les talibans le
représentant communautaire veut nous
montrer la détresse de la population
comme il n'y a pas assez à manger les
enfants deviennent de plus en plus
faible elle est là c'est ton et l5 elle
a l'air plus petit qu elle parce qu'elle
est mal nourrie
je suis malade et des mois what u mal
j'ai mal ici
diatta
que la paix soit sur vous comment allez
vous
comment ça se passe pour vous et votre
mari est il allé travailler
nous n'avons rien alors il est allé
ramasser des plantes pour faire du
cheveu qu'on prépare du thé parce que
nous avons fait l'un avoue que du pain
et de l'eau et on ne mange du pain que
le soir quand on a rien on boit de l'eau
seulement il n'avons pas d'argent pour
acheter de la nourriture que nos enfants
pour nous mêmes
du pain rassis dans de l'eau c'est ce
que mange essentiellement les familles
ici
selon l'onu plus d'un million d'enfants
afghans de moins de cinq ans sont
menacés de malnutrition dans la province
d'herat thil sont hospitalisés dans cet
hôpital soutenu par médecins sans
frontières voici l'une des chambres de
notre unité de soins intensifs de notre
service de malnutrition les chances de
survie de ces patients sont très faibles
s'ils ne reçoivent pas de soins médicaux
les mères qui accompagnent leurs bébés
souffrent souvent elles aussi de
malnutrition
l'année dernière une de mes filles est
morte
elle avait un moi je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle avait bien eu la sécheresse et
c'était une très mauvaise année
financièrement pour nous maintenant la
même chose est en train d'arriver à ma
fille de 6 mois
les bébés pèsent tous beaucoup moins que
ce qu'ils devraient à leur âge
la situation en afghanistan est
préoccupante il est vrai que nous
observons non seulement à et rate mais
aussi ailleurs plus de cas de
malnutrition que les années précédentes
et non seulement plus d'enfants
souffrent de malnutrition mais aussi
plus de femmes enceintes ou qui
allaitent leur bébé
plongé dans la misère sans espoir d'un
avenir meilleur certaines familles en
viennent à commettre l'inimaginable
le mari de cette femme a vendu il ya
moins d'un an à son insu leur fille âgée
de 9 ans à un homme qui en a 40 de plus
la fillette vie pour l'instant toujours
avec sa mère qui tente de rembourser cet
homme
même si nous mourrons de faim je ne
pourrais pas à vendre ma fille j'ai déjà
remboursé dix neuf mille afghani sur
100000 que je dois à cet homme j'ai très
peur car si je ne paie pas le reste de
l'argent elle me prendre à ma fille
mon père m'a vendu parce qu'il avait
besoin d'argent qui n'avions rien à
manger il m'a vendu parce qu'il le
devait et ma mère a essayé de l'en
empêcher
il n'y a personne pour nous aider il n'y
a pas de travail et j'ai tellement de
dette je ne sais pas quoi faire je ne
sais pas s'il existe une solution à
ceignac
[Musique]
la détresse est immense dans le pays 23
millions de personnes soit plus de la
moitié de la population souffrent de
faim aiguë